it was a very different Britain that
woke up this morning normally busy roads
were hushed as most people acted on the
government's new measures in this
residential area of Basingstoke those
venturing out for essentials kept their
distance but did stop to chat about what
life was like under the coronavirus
locked down my system needed the pair of
glasses I had to put that side she's a
carer so she can't come to me I come I'm
a cab a key worker I can't come near her
she can't come near me difficult times
vary but the government's command to
stay at home is proving hard for some
people
Martin and Dennis are self-employed
painters with kids to feed and rent to
pay they say they have no choice but to
work to be done isn't it I understand
but the only reason I'm out here is
because of the money to provide for my
family
that's the only reason not to spread the
virus around Britain keeping people at
arm's length is the new normal exercise
once a day is allowed and in this Park
in London social distancing was strictly
practiced I'm taking this pretty
seriously I mean I know quite a few
people who've been ill my grandmother's
in intensive care with the virus the
government says the lockdown will be
reviewed after three weeks but what's
being asked to stay at home will take a
huge effort by the British public key
workers are allowed to go to work as
normal and for them including
journalists like me it means taking
extra precautions all interviews are
done with a boom mic so that we can keep
our distance and keep people and
ourselves safe and he's septic gel and
wipes used regularly and of course the
cameraman and I am at least 6 feet apart
at all times and when it comes to
travelling to location well we go in
separate cars the next few weeks will
then be an enormous challenge
never before in modern times as the
country being under lockdown in fact
you'd need to reach back to the plagues
of the 17th century to make a comparison
if you fell sick of play
yourself and anyone who was in your own
household would be locked in as they
called it or shut-in for 40 days and
nights and during which time you weren't
able to leave the house he weren't even
able able to open a window but the
nation's resilience is already beginning
to show in towns and cities
homeschooling and PE lessons gather pace
this may not be over soon but the
country Alex Rossy Sky News